you don't have to search far on social
media to find posts like these simple
videos or still images advertising
illegal drugs it is a growing phenomenon
and the first definitive study has
revealed one and four young people have
been exposed to these ads even more
alarmingly those who carried out this
research over recent months believe the
number is now much higher how many of
you have ever seen an advert on social
media advertising drugs every one of you
these teenagers say they've seen an
explosion and the number of drugs ads on
the likes of Instagram Facebook and
snapchat things like cannabis and any I
just really like soft drugs everything's
available now online on social media
almost everywhere because in our current
day and age the internet and social
media is in everything we do so I think
it is really worrying people can joke
around about being friends with their
drug dealer cuz the dynamic between drug
dealer and buyer has completely changed
before it's no longer this scary concept
of meeting someone you know hooded on
the streets now it's just someone the
friendly message every so often it
shouldn't really be surprising that drug
dealers like the rest of us are
increasingly using modern technology it
has for them significant advantages they
don't have to do their deals in dark
alleys and on street corners and hard
press police forces simply aren't
monitoring social media but this former
dealer says although the purchase of
drugs on social media may appear benign
there are still risks you still mean
some dodgy guy at the end of the day you
don't know wreck really what you're
buying you know who this guy is it could
be a scam for all you know like I'd say
just because on social media doesn't
mean it's necessarily safer the advocacy
group fought fires who commissioned the
studies say the proliferation of drug
dealers on social media has almost
become normalized young people we see
say yes we are seeing these adverts and
what we find
I guess surprising is how unconcerned
they were by it for them it's a normal
part they say like
the older generation I don't think they
realize that times have changed and they
might not see it in the street anymore
if they're not on snapchat Instagram
then they still might not see it because
it depends on who you follow
I don't think social media is going away
anytime soon so the quicker we stop
focusing on trying to stop the young
people using these platforms and just
educate them properly to deal with
messages that the dealers may send is
when we'll really start to make a
difference snapchat Instagram and
Facebook say they don't tolerate the
sale of drugs on their platforms and
used the latest in technology to
identify and remove users advertising
illicit substances mark white Sky News